já há a fazer vou contar pra vocês uma
teoria que eu recentemente descobri que
eu acho que é muito interessante
nós gostamos sentido apesar de parecer
às vezes sai não sei se todos vocês já
pensar em coisas tipo a imagina se todos
nós somos estamos vivendo uma célula no
corpo de outra pessoa ou o mundo todo
é um sonho e as outras pessoas são
criações da minha mente coisas assim
são temas tipo desaparece em nosso
dia-a-dia de uma maneira tendo uma
conversa diferente estranha sobre a
nossa existência mas também são temas
filosóficos e tem gente que leva eles de
maneira séria e acadêmica
eu vou falar sobre uma teoria é um
artigo na verdade acho que dilma 57
páginas desse cara chamado nick bostrom
e ele é professor na universidade óculos
e uma teoria muito interessante que diz
que de acordo com o nosso crescimento
tecnológico atual ea maneira com que ele
aconteceu na história que a gente pode
ver algumas descobertas por exemplo à
imprensa que foi 1.400 mas depois só 200
anos depois da descoberta o telescópio e
tipo sendo 50 depois há o o motor e
depois começam a se achar descobertas
cada vez uma maneira mais rápida faz um
gráfico exponencial assim de que as
descobertas cada vez acontecem mais
rápido que importa para essa teoria
ela diz que é plausível alguma hora na
nossa existência a gente tem tecnologia
suficiente para simular o universo se
não muito parecido com o nosso parecido
suficiente para os humanos que estão
dentro dele não perceberem que ele é
falso que é uma simulação a gente vai
ter computadores
talvez 10 mil anos fortes o suficiente
potente o suficiente para simular a
nossa realidade com uma uma de uma
maneira de dinheiro suficiente maneira
que parece real para os humanos
esse é o primeiro ponto o segundo ponto
mas tá a gente acredita nisso também
acredita que a mente humana funciona de
uma maneira com isso físicas com leis
biológicas que é mais ou menos
previsível de acordo com a nossa
tecnologia a gente chega
o nível tecnológico suficiente pra prevê
isso é tem como prever não é impossível
de uma perspectiva por exemplo tem um
deus o que tem livre arbítrio é uma
coisa determina tipos humanos não teriam
totalmente livre arbítrio seriam regidos
por algumas leis da física e da ce que
fazem com que ele se comporte de maneira
que eles se comportam essas são as duas
premissas necessárias para essa teoria
então é isso
partindo desse ponto tem três conclusões
possíveis e eu vou mostrar a elas e como
não é tão sujo pensar que é possível que
a gente tem hoje vivendo numa simulação
agora a primeira alternativa disse que a
espécie humana vai ser extinta
antes de chegar ao nível de tecnologia
necessário para fazer a simulação tem
algumas explicações de porque ela vai
ser extinta e uma que eu acho que é bem
interessante se chama paradoxo de ferro
o que ele diz e foi originalmente feito
pra falar de alienígenas e de como
porque numa galáxia no universo tão
grande quanto o nosso nunca nenhuma
espécie allen nos contatou a gente
conseguiu conversar com eles e o que ele
diz o seguinte pra te ter aqui no
necessária para viajar no espaço para
chegar no planeta terra de uma trégua
láctea que tenha vida
a civilização que chegar nessa
tecnologia vai ter que ter passado por
tecnologias muito destrutivas uma bomba
atômica por exemplo e algum momento de
evolução ela vai ter sido extinto por
uma guerra algum problema assim e por
isso ninguém nunca teve a tecnologia
necessária para viajar pra casa
aqui eu fiz uma comparação dizendo que o
ano já estão mais ou menos estágios for
ver isso aqui é a bomba de hiroshima
isso aqui a bomba nuclear mais forte que
a gente já produziu então tipo silva de
jesus tem uma cidade inteira não sei que
eles conseguiram destruir fosse detonada
então é possível que a gente seja
extinto antes de chegar aqui nesse nível
o segundo
a segunda hipótese é que a gente pode
chegar no nível tecnológico suficiente
para fazer essa simulação mas por algum
motivo os humanos não vão ter interesse
em fazer ela por exemplo se chega lá mas
em algum conselho em alguma coisa e ele
disse que não é ético simular uma coisa
como a gente
a ideia seria simular por exemplo
humanos antigos para entender como eles
pensavam no nosso tempo ou prender pra
testar um produto novo que eles têm medo
que seja destrutivo no universo deles
disse
é uma coisa nova pra testar isso mas
eles decidirem bom não é moral ou imoral
criar seres conscientes
então a gente não vai fazer isso é
proibido e ninguém faz isso é um pouco o
que eles não está tão desenvolvidos
humanos que ninguém vai ter interesse
entre isso eles vão ter coisas mais
legais para fazer o quê também é
possível pode usar as suas duas
primeiras forem falsas
é muito provável que a gente esteja
vivendo uma moça porque vou explicar
bom se a humanidade base chegou no nível
necessário para a simulação primeira
eles simularam uma coisa parecida com
eles é muito provável que a coisa
parecida com eles foi parecido eficiente
também crie uma simulação boa o
suficiente essa emoção vai criar outra
então se a primeira criou o que quer
dizer se nós humanos chegarem e se
chegarmos a um nível de criar uma
simulação assim é muito provável que a
gente seja uma simulação nós mesmos
porque essa gente criou é muito provável
que os dois tenham criados porque é esse
tipo isso se segue é logicamente então é
meio ruim pensar nisso e outra ou de
outra o outro paradoxo pode acontecer
que se a gente chega lá ea gente sabe
isso agora a gente chega lá e perceber
que a gente quer a gente também vai ser
uma criação a gente decida não criar
para ter certeza que a gente não é uma
criação então ninguém vai ser uma
criação mas isso é uma possibilidade
outra possibilidade interessante que
emerge dessa coisa de realidade base
realidade não base é que ninguém nunca
vai saber quem é a realidade base porque
se eles criaram é possível que
anteriores tenham criado também logo tem
alguém pra manga o que a gente está
fazendo isso em algum programa no que a
gente está fazendo tem julgando nossas
opções morais
então deus é criado porque tem gente
programando em cima de mim eu posso
querer atuar de uma maneira moral pra
ser premiado por exemplo me reprogramar
em quando eu morrer em uma vida após a
morte por exemplo então a justificativa
pra gente agir de uma maneira ética e
outra coisa que tipo e se uniu de matrix
que é uma relacionada matrix mas o que
eu quero e outra coisa que acontece é
que bom se a gente criar e como disse
tipo não é a chance de a gente se a
realidade base é ridículo tipo 1 bilhão
porque ele infinitos os números
simulações possíveis de ser feitas e bom
então a gente também deve ser uma
simulação de acordo com isso
an é isso que eu queria dizer é um é
como seria interessante pensar e não é
tão implausível segurança e sistema
lógico tipo e o que muda na nossa vida
não muda nada a gente tem que continuar
se preocupando que a gente vai comer o
outro dia com quem a gente gosta a gente
vai fazer mas é uma coisa que pode estar
acontecendo a gente pode na verdade está
no computador de humanas daqui há 10 mil
anos